bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
comme chaque semaine nous sommes ici au
parlement européen à bruxelles et dans
cette émission nous allons aller en
roumanie qui est désormais confronté au
problème des déserts médicaux
de plus en plus de médecins roumains
souhaitent s'installer en europe de
l'ouest pour améliorer leurs conditions
de travail et augmenter leurs salaires
mais l'actualité de la semaine ça reste
l'europe confrontée aux scandales de la
viande de cheval mais également à la
réintroduction des farines animales
notre invité sera josé bové mais tout de
suite cette question avec nora m'a dit
qu'y at-il dans nos assiettes
ils ne mouraient pas tous mais tous
étaient frappés les pays d'abord royaume
uni italie france espagne suède irlande
finlande et les industries findus picard
mais c'est vrai mais qu'est donc ce mal
qui répand la terreur
sont ce des animaux malades de la peste
nom du canasson de la simple viande de
canassons oui mais de la viande de
cheval à la place de la viande de boeuf
c'est prendre les vessies pour des
lanternes non mais voilà la chaire de
cheval est bien moins cher donc dans les
lasagnes cela fait désordre
pensez donc des industriels
augmenteraient leurs marges en trompant
le consommateur non vous ne pensez pas
et derrière c'est la sacro-sainte
question de la traçabilité qui se pose
alors qu'y at-il dans nos assiettes
qu'y at-il dans nos assiettes josé bové
bonjour bonjour
vaste question alors vous êtes député
européen français du groupe des verts
vous êtes vice-président de la
commission agriculture ici au parlement
européen qu'est ce que ce scandale de la
viande de cheval
qu'est ce que ça dit du fonctionnement
européen avant est ce que c'est un
scandale européen selon vous alors moi
je dirais que c'est un scandale
au niveau de l'europe mais c'est un
scandale de la chaîne alimentaire d'
envoi de l'agro industrie c'est là que
la logique des bas prix comme c'est bien
d'être expliquée ont réduit les coûts en
maximalise les profits on est dans celle
dans ce schéma là et donc plus on
rallonge la chaîne alimentaire plus on a
une logique industrielle de la
production entre le producteur et le
consommateur va fatalement on arrive à
ce gentil sème donc c'est pas l'europe
qui est en cause dans cette affaire
c'est très clairement un modèle agro
alimentaire qui a été poussé évidemment
par un certain nombre de lobbies et sur
lesquelles la commission malgré tout à
donner son aval
alors depuis le début de cette affaire
l'europe ne cesse de dire nous
ondées dicte les normes et ensuite c'est
aux pays aux états membres de faire les
contrôles en impression quand même un
petit peu de qu'elle se défausse sur les
sur les différents états est-ce que ça
correspond à une réalité ce que c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne alors c'est
vrai que il ya une agence européenne
sanitaire des aliments
la us af ça en anglais qui a un contrôle
qui est née du scandale de la vache
folle et d'eau l'idée c'est
effectivement connaît un contrôle
européen
mais ce sont les états membres
effectivement qui de plus en plus on la
délégation pour agir
le dernier exemple en date c'est sûr
justement le contrôle liée à la vache
folle et bien la commission européenne
et vient de dire aux états vous pouvez
arrêter
nous on vous autorise à arrêter tout
contrôle sur la vache mais arrêtons nous
un instant là dessus justement ce que
vous dites c'est que la commission dit
maintenant ce n'est plus nécessaire de
faire des contrôles sur les vaches pour
savoir si elles sont si elles sont
malades delà de la maladie de vache
folle c'est terminé s'est terminée le 4
février donc dans un document officiel
que j'ai ici
la commission vient de dire aux états
membres vous pouvez arrêter les
contrôles sur la vache folle
or on sait que cette année il ya eu 28
cas de vache folle
donc on voit bien comment quelle est la
logique
on est dans cette logique politique qui
évolue d'ailleurs par le conseil des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement on
dirait de renationaliser les politiques
et ça je pense que c'est très dangereux
de ramener les politiques il faut qu'on
ait un véritable contrôle et une
politique européenne et ensuite les
états appliquent cette politique
européenne ne peut pas laisser aux états
la liberté ou non de dire on arrête les
contrôles sur la vague ça n'a pas de
sens
et bien c'est la même chose sur les
farines animales c'est la même chose sur
la rapide des verts justement le à
propos de cette information là que vous
venez de nous
ivre et donc plus de plus de contrôle
sur sur la vache folle plus on sait le
retour des farines animales dans
l'alimentation des poissons dans un
premier temps est ce que ça veut dire
que finalement la commission européenne
estime qu'il ya plus de danger vis-à-vis
de l'usb et puis d'autre part est-ce
qu'elle a pas raison parce qu après tout
peut-être que s'est terminée cette
affaire alors on pourrait l'entendre de
cette manière là sauf que sur le prion
on n'a toujours pas véritablement de
connaissances scientifiques on nous
avait dit que ça pouvait pas passer la
barrière des espèces l'homme a été
contaminé donc on a des vrais problèmes
et puis encore des cas donc le problème
c'est qu'à partir du moment où on a
réintroduit on enclenche le processus
pour réintroduire les farines animales
ce qui était un véritable scandale
d'abord pour les poissons quoi on nous
dit on nous dit moi je que les farines
animales d'aujourd'hui ne sont plus
celles de des années 2000 90 et 2000 qui
ont favorisé l'extension de la maladie
de la vache folle est ce qu'on va se
tourner est ce que c'est vrai ce que ces
farines animales ont vraiment changé
alors dans un premier temps on nous dit
seuls les farines animales à partir de
porcs et de volailles vont être données
aux poissons puis ensuite au port puis
ensuite aux volailles ça c'est le le
schéma idéal on est toujours un peu chez
les bisounours puisqu'en réalité on sait
très bien qu'à partir du moment où on
est dans ce processus
on aura des dérives avec justement la
même scandale qui s'est passé pour la
viande de cheval qui a été prise pour de
la vache on aura des trafiquants on aura
tout un système industriel qui va
chercher à optimiser donc comme ça
coûtera pas cher d'avoir des farines
animales
eh bien on va les réintroduire et dc 1 2
5 ans j'en sais rien on aura un nouveau
scandale de farines animales de beauvais
on ira mais on n'avait pas prévu c'est
parce qu'ils étaient dans les textes
sûrs qu'à partir du moment où on ouvre
la porte pandore eh bien on se retrouve
à nouveau dans le scandale je vais faire
à mon tour le bisounours
pourquoi la commission européenne les
stèles faire ça pourquoi est-ce qu'elle
autorise le retour des farines animales
pourquoi il ya plus de contrôle sur la
vallée de la vache folle qu'est ce qu'il
ya derrière
pour moi c'est très clair on a une
logique de lobbying très puissant
aujourd'hui de l'agro alimentaire
industriel
aujourd'hui ils veulent à tout prix et
dans la conquête de marchés
donc on a des marques on a parlé de
celles qui sont le circuit le packaging
aux plus chers que les produits qui sont
à l'intérieur
donc on diminue les coûts et à partir de
là on inonde les marchés donc dans ce
processus industriels effectivement on
doit au fur et à mesure avoir le plus de
liberté au niveau de la circulation des
marchandises et on a un vrai danger
donc la question aujourd'hui c'est
comment un pour sécuriser les
consommateurs et deux pour permettre aux
paysans de vivre ont raccourci la chaîne
alimentaire
on remet par exemple en service ont
reconstruit des abattoirs de proximité
parce que la restauration collective est
importante et donc senna elle peut se
faire à partir de la proximité
il faut revisiter complètement la
politique agricole commune puisque c'est
dans ce cas de l'actrice faire et dans
le cadre du développement rural qui
était un des chapitres de cette pac
l'objectif très clairement c'est de
relocaliser la production agricole
ce que vous nous dites en fait c'est que
bruxelles pour des raisons financières
et parce qu'elle est très influencé par
part du lobbying finalement lève les
barrières et les sphères de nouveau
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire dire
vous êtes en ce sens scandalisé par par
ces affaires est-ce que vous avez des
actions est ce que comme comment vous
allez faire pour parce que là c'est
finalement c'est fait tout ça c'est fait
et donc qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que
vous en tant que député européen et du
groupe des verts qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire d'abord un c'est le mettre
sur la place publique et le fait que je
sois ici au parlement me permet
effectivement d'interpeller de manière
beaucoup plus large donc là c'est très
important
ensuite on va mener des actions au
niveau des différents députés au niveau
des états et ont barré importerait
interpellé le commissaire qui a mis en
place ces processus parce que c'est pas
parce que c'est autorisé qu on ne peut
pas revenir en arrière
et pour moi il est très clair qu'il faut
revenir en arrière mais au terme
si au 1er juin ces farines sont
autorisés dans l'élevage des poissons
eh bien on va mener des actions
publiques pour appeler au boycott du
poisson d'élevage et on va appeler aussi
certainement des actions
pour aller sortir des magasins ces
produits aux farines animales d'un mot
josé bové delphine batho la ministre
française appelle à la création d'un
d'un d'un label poisson sens en farines
animales
est ce que ça vous paraît crédible
m'écouter c'est un début sauf quand on
est dans le cadre européen
donc c'est pas au niveau d'un pays parce
que les industriels ou que les
producteurs les pisciculteurs français
dit on n'utilise pas et five c'est un
première chose simplement le marché est
ouvert et il y aura pas que ce type de
poisson dans les étals donc il faut que
ce soit une législation européenne
pour moi il faut interdire les farines
animales mais si l'addition
il faut qu'ils un étiquetage obligatoire
comme ça le consommateur il suppléera
marqué en gros nourri aux farines
animales ça m'étonnerait qu'ils aient
envie d'en acheter merci josé bové
d'avoir accepté cette invitation dans
leur hôtel de un autre sujet d'actualité
au niveau européen c'est celui du budget
les 27 chefs d'états vous savez se sont
mis d'accord sur un budget européen pour
les 7 ans à venir
évidemment les télévisions européennes
en ont parlé on regarde ce zapping signé
aurélie la face
après 24 heures de combat accord sur le
budget et sur les télévisions
européennes on compte les points
david cameron est proclamé vainqueur ce
fut une bataille entre le président
français d'un côté et le premier
ministre britannique de l'autre sur
l'argent dont a besoin l'europe et sur
qui doit le toucher les médias français
ont déclaré leur président perdant il
affirme qu'il a été abandonné par la
chancelière allemande alors défaite ou
victoire pour l'union entre la rtbf et
les dirigeants européens
les avis divergent tout cela ressemble à
une défaite pour l'europe
et pourtant étrangement tout le monde
est content et c'est un budget pour le
futur
fioutch c'était l'objectif que je
m'étais fixé le budget européen
heureusement présente des mesures
positives mais déjà la belle victoire
s'effrite le parlement européen fait
entendre une note dissonante
ce budget ne lui convient pas nous ne
pouvons pas accepter que d'un côté nous
exigions des états membres un
assainissement de leurs budgets et je
suis pour cela et que nous commencions
ici à créer du déficit
cela nous interdit de signer un tel
budget je ne le ferai pas alors nous
sommes avec isabelle ory bonjour les
appels vous êtes la correspondante de la
radio française europe 1 ici ici à
bruxelles
on a entendu le président du parlement
européen qui montre un peu ses muscles
et qui dit ce budget on va pas le signer
alors c'est vrai que ce qu'on sait peu
c'est que le parlement européen a le
droit maintenant d'opposer son veto à ce
budget qu'est ce que vous pensez que le
parlement européen va avoir le courage
politique de le faire
je pense que c'est vraiment une sorte de
cadeau empoisonné pour le parlement
parce que c'est vrai vous l'avez dit
c'est la première fois ils ont ce
pouvoir
alors évidemment c'est tentant on se dit
est ce qu'ils vont s'en servir ce qui
vont du coup montrer la puissance
puisque à part après tout eux
représentent les citoyens européens face
aux états et aux à ce qu'on appelait les
égoïsmes des états et en même temps ce
parlement européen il est composé de
délégations nationales
si on prend la france par exemple il ya
une délégation socialiste art qu'est ce
qu'elle va faire
le parti socialiste européen a dit qu'il
fallait pas voter ce budget est la
délégation socialiste est ce qu'elle va
faire comme françois hollande sans moi
c'est votre pronostic c'est quoi moi je
pense qu'ils vont ils vont négocier
jusqu en juillet qu'ils vont obtenir
quelques concessions qui seront
peut-être un peu technique à comprendre
d'ailleurs pour pour les spectateurs
mais qui vont leur permettre de s'en
sortir en disant voilà on a obtenu ça on
a par exemple obtenu qu'on recourt
regarde le budget dans deux ans et là
est à mon avis ils vont
je pense qu'il faut voter ce budget au
pas de déconner grappin sur le fond ce
budget ce qu'il nous semble être un
budget en régression comme beaucoup de
médias l'ont dit je serai sur le coup
c'est ce qu'on a dit de manière forte
parce que effectivement le budget il est
plus bas que ce qu'on pensait sur ce qui
est compliqué finalement de savoir parce
qu'on sait pas très bien ce qui va se
passer sur les septembre il ya eu
beaucoup de débats un peu technique il
ya des choses qui ont été introduites
qui permettent finalement pas de savoir
avec précision ce qu'il faisait il ya
plus d'argent dans les budgets recherche
innovation quand même qu'avant il y en a
moins sûr sur la pac par exemple
qu'avant donc à la fin c'est en volume
global c'est moins que ce qu'on avait ce
que ce que les européens avaient espéré
et en même temps il est mieux répartie
dont finalement à la fin c'est une c'est
une demi déception beaucoup de
détracteurs de cette de cet accord dont
qui a été signé ici à bruxelles par les
27 chefs d'états 10 le budget européen
en fait c'est un budget de l'europe du
passé par exemple c'est la politique
agricole commune et c est ça ne
correspond pas aux besoins de l'europe
du futur est ce que vous qui partager
cette opinion
je trouve que c'est un budget des
égoïsmes nationaux sauf que c'est un
budget on additionne tous les intérêts
des différents pays alors par exemple
effectivement les français se sont arc
boutés sur la pac pour maintenir à peu
près les volumes des crédits alors
qu'ils auraient dû accepter qu'on baisse
pour pouvoir plus financer la croissance
effectivement de ce point de vue là
c'est un budget du passé mais quand même
cette fois ci il ya plus pour la
croissance qu'il y avait dans les
budgets précédents donc finalement ce
n'est pas si négatif que ce qui a été
dit au moment de 2,7 à corriger à
bruxelles
j'ai l'impression que sur sur le moment
on l'a tous trouvé très négatif mais que
sur le mans c'est très compliqué de
juger un budget campus et explications
qu'on nous donne sont extrêmement
techniques à ce fonds au coeur de la
nuit
ce budget il est désolant faut quand
même voir que c'est moins d'un pour cent
du budget l'union antenne donc si on se
place dans une logique d'ambition
européenne
il est désolant si on se place dans ce
qu'il était possible d'obtenir
finalement bon s'est passé plein désert
merci en tout cas isabelle ory d'avoir
accepté notre invitation on va rester
évidemment dans les affaires européennes
et nous allons partir en roumanie se
trouve que on a peut-être vu dans les
hôpitaux vous l'avez peut-être vu comme
moi et souvent des médecins roumains ici
en europe de l'ouest et bien ces
médecins manquent dans leur propre pays
là bas ça devient un désert médical
voici un reportage réalisé en roumanie
par marie brémaud et mehdi chez balland
c'était scandant non vous accompagnez
monsieur il a un problème
cela fait 13 ans que christian paire
ianu et médecin urgentiste
il exerce dans le plus important hôpital
public de iasi deuxième ville de
roumanie l'hôpital saint spiridon
tourner tant bien que mal il faudrait 25
% de médecins en plus pour sortir du
sous effectif chronique drôle de look
rose à ce qu il y avait beaucoup de
boulot c'est difficile de dire combien
d'heures on travaille par jour car on
travaille beaucoup aussi sur notre temps
libre pour gagner un peu plus mais bon
par rapport à un romain lambda c'est
vrai que notre niveau de vie est
meilleure mais on doit se former
lire apprendre des autres tout en
assumant notre rôle de parent avoir
avoir une vie chronique du match dit moi
quand ça vous fait même ici que l'on
sache qu'il a
j'espère aller respirer profondément
avec son travail l'enseignement et des
extras christian arrive à gagner 1000
euros par mois un salaire peu élevé pour
un métier difficile qui requiert dix ans
d'études
il lui arrive d'envisager de partir en
belgique ou ailleurs
son profil est très recherché récemment
j'ai reçu des offres de la part de
plusieurs agences de recrutement des
agences de recrutement qui sont très
agressives elles recherchent du
personnel qualifié pour travailler à
l'ouest
à l'ouest de l'europe des déserts
médicaux en roumanie
le malaise de médecins qui se sentent
bien souvent dénigré et souffre d'un
manque de reconnaissance
ici les politiques de santé ne
représentent que 4% du produit intérieur
brut contre 10% en moyenne en europe
isabelle à 30 ans et dans quelques mois
alors a achevé son internat sa
spécialité anesthésie en soins intensifs
elle l'exercera a sans doute pour un
temps tout du moins ailleurs un pêcheur
ce serait l'occasion d'une nouvelle
expérience dans un hôpital où il y a une
bonne organisation et des moyens
conséquents chez et bien sûr il y à
l'argent tout le monde sait qu'on est
mieux payé à l'étranger qu'en roumanie
je choisirais bien la france car je
parle la langue
et puis j'ai beaucoup de collègues qui
sont déjà et qui ont des expériences
réussies là bas
la france et la belgique des
destinations privilégiées
les roumains sont francophones depuis
l'adhésion du pays à l'union européenne
en 2007
l'équivalence des diplômes et la libre
circulation le phénomène est alarmant en
cinq ans 14 mille médecins ont quitté la
roumanie alors que sur la même période
seuls douze mille achever leur internat
en roumanie un peu moins de deux
médecins pour 1000 habitants quand la
moyenne en europe et de 3,7
l'ordre des médecins roumains assiste
impuissant à une hémorragie qui dure et
s'accentue si ce genre d'exode continue
dans quelques années le système de santé
roumain va péricliter
c'est une situation très grave mais
malheureusement les hommes politiques
roumains ne comprennent pas à cela et
n'ont pris aucune mesure pour les
inciter à rester dans notre système de
santé mais laitiers insisté à mon dessin
à tâter à longuenesse
à la faculté de médecine de iasi l'heure
est aux examens pour ces étudiants en
première année
bordeaux n'a de cesse d'aller là bas pas
encore doctor est pourtant un quart
d'entre eux a déjà le regard tourné vers
l'ouest qui pense parmi vous qu'il
travaillera à l'étranger lever la main
ceux pour qui c'est le cas depuis 2007
cette fuite des médecins auraient déjà
coûté à l'état un rhume 1,3 milliard
d'euros
une grande partie de la formation est
prise en charge par les pouvoirs publics
alors des voix s'élèvent pour demander
aux pays qui attire et profite de ses
médecins de mettre la main à la poche
une sorte de juste retour sur
investissement pour la roumanie
voilà pour ce reportage
en roumanie c'est marie brémaud et mehdi
chebana retour avant que ça nous a
rejoints sur ce plateau philippe
boulland bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
député vous êtes députés ppe
vous êtes également médecin et surtout
spécialiste des déserts médicaux est ce
que vous êtes étonné que ces déserts
médicaux sont désormais une
problématique roumanie n'ont absolument
pas on sait que le classement des des
problèmes de démographie médicale
mais cuba en tête des pays les mieux
dotés la france à peu près 25e mais la
roumanie 65e donc comme il ya beaucoup
de médecins roumains et personnellement
dans mon cabinet j'ai une femme
remplaçante quand je suis au parlement
européen qui est roumaine donc je
connais bien le problème
effectivement nous aggravons ce problème
en roumanie alors justement est ce que
vous comprenez que ces jeunes médecins
ou moins jeunes médecins roumains soient
attirés par des meilleures conditions de
travail et surtout des salaires plus
important oui un tout d'abord dans votre
reportage on parlait d'un urgentiste il
ya 2000 euros par mois c'est assez
exceptionnel en roumanie et en règle
générale il ya une entre 200 et 400
euros par mois
ma remplaçante gagne beaucoup plus dans
les 5000 6000 euros par mois et c'est
quand même beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
intéressant dans des conditions de
travail qui sont quand même beaucoup
plus confortable et financièrement plus
attrayante
on se retrouve avec un pays la roumanie
qui est un des taux de médecins d parmi
les plus faibles d'europe on se retrouve
avec 1,9 médecins pour 1000 habitants
c'est insuffisant ah oui c'est
insuffisant nous en france on estime qu'
on est à 2 5 médecins pour 1000
habitants à peu près donc on estime déjà
qu'on est en pénurie de médecins alors
vous imaginez la roumanie c'est bien
bien pires alors on est une question
pour vous c'est une question de vasile
astarastoaie c'est l'équivalent du
président de l'ordre des médecins en
roumanie on les coûts tout de suite
quand existera-t-il un mécanisme qui va
éliminer les inégalités entre les
systèmes de santé des différents états
membres
alors voilà qu'est ce que vous répondez
à cette question à quand une
harmonisation à l'harmonisation c'est
très difficile en europe en règle
générale sur tous domaines confondus il
faut plutôt parler de convergence et la
réalisation c'est parfois un gros mot un
peu ici mais je pense qu'il faut essayer
de mettre sur pied des systèmes qui
permettent d'équilibrer voilà c'est
peut-être le terme à retenir
d'équilibrer les problèmes de
démographie médicale en europe
et moi j'avais préconisé il ya un an ou
deux ans dans le cadre de la campagne
présidentielle que l'on mette vraiment
le focus et les projecteurs sur des des
solutions qui pourraient permettre de
résoudre les problèmes graphiques
médical et j'avais avancé une une
proposition qui normalement la résolvez
en moins de trois ans basée sur la
télémédecine et cette télé médecine elle
peut s'appliquer à l'ensemble des
territoires européens
donc en maintenant des les populations
médicale dans les territoires mais là
concrètement qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est
un pillage des médecins ou mal d la
roumanie en train de perdre tous ses
médecins à court terme qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour régler ce problème
alors c'est individuellement c'est très
difficile parce que quand on est médecin
roumain
j'ai essayé mon vécu en tout cas vient
vous le sollicitez veut travailler par
la langue est compétent a le droit
légalement de venir s'installer en
france
comment refuser voilà maintenant la
problématique des des roumains elle est
différente
il faut que l'état roumain assume aussi
le le bas coût des salaires des médecins
à rouen donc il ya une il ya des
décisions politiques à prendre en
roumanie et les décisions politiques à
prendre en europe reviennent pas
seulement en france on a entendu
inégalement belgique qui viennent
également en angleterre ou en allemagne
c'est un problème typique de l'europe de
l'ouest aujourd'hui oui parce que je
pense que les rémunérations sont plus
attractives en europe de l'ouest qu'en
dehors de l'est évidemment à quatre fois
supérieur mais voilà donc évidemment
rien que ça déjà ça ça pose le problème
ensuite il ya des régions en france où
on a trois quarts de médecins étrangers
qui ne sont pas que romain nous avons
aussi beaucoup d'une population de
médecins maghrébins qui est assez
importante donc le vraiment en france
c'est pas du pillage au long terme et on
ne peut pas ne pas accueillir des
médecins qui en plus nous rendre service
et rendre service à notre population
alors en france il ya un problème de
numerus clausus qui a été relevé est-ce
que c'est pas absurde aujourd'hui de
d'avoir cette limitation est ce qu'on
pourrait pas formé beaucoup plus de
médecins en france
si c'est ce qu'on dit depuis des années
des années le numerus clausus a augmenté
de 10% quelques années c'est ridicule au
regard des besoins de la population
donc on aurait dû il ya longtemps
augmenter encore plus le numerus clausus
pour autant il faut être quand même un
peu sélectif mais on a
on n'a absolument pas pur moment de
d'équivalence et tant que lé toutes les
autres solutions proposées par les
gouvernements ne sont pas ne permettent
pas de pallier ces problèmes de défauts
de médecins soyons clair vous aviez
adresser lettre à l'époque à nicolas
sarkozy lorsqu'il était président de la
république sur le problème des déserts
médicaux
que ce soit des déserts médicaux en
france en roumanie que vous êtes pour la
liberté d'installation
mais à une condition est-ce que vous
pouvez nous l'a rappelé et il faudra une
période un petit peu de transition avant
de choisir le lieu où on s'installe
moi j'ai vécu ça dans des pays du
tiers-monde et pays émergents où on a ce
type de dispositif qui marche très bien
et donc je pense qu'en france si on veut
autoriser un médecin tout en maintenant
la liberté d'installation autoriser un
médecin sar est dans une zone
relativement correctement dotées ou
surdotées il faut l'obliger à vent à
faire quelques années dans un territoire
sous dotées peut-être que ce médecin se
plaira découvrira ce territoire
l'adoptera y vivre il restera donc
pourquoi pas c'est un challenge
maintenant après il aura l'autorisation
d'aller ailleurs
mais entre temps il y aura un turnover
réguliers sur trois ans quatre ans
d'installation dans ces territoires sous
l'autel déjà rien que ça ça solutionne
une partie du problème
l'autre pan de monde la proposition
était basée sur la télémédecine les plus
optimistes disent que c'est peut être
bénéfique pour la roumanie cet exil des
médecins roumains puisque à long terme
ils reviendront peut-être en roumanie
cela bénéficiera l'ensemble du système
de santé aux mains est ce que vous
croyez à un retour de ces médecins
ensuite en roumanie
pas du tout je pense pas je pense que
tant que les conditions de l'exercice
médical en roumanie et sont telles
qu'elles sont la date d'aujourd'hui ils
reviendront pas et ferais vraiment ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure qui
est un changement politique chez eux ce
politique social économique évidemment
donc les médecins qui sont chez nous en
france s'y plaisent s'installe se
regroupent d'ailleurs moi je vois
beaucoup de regroupements communautaires
et
et je pense que c'est gage d'une
installation à long terme il ne faut
rien faire pour limiter les
autorisations les déplacements de
médecins à travers l'europe c'est c'est
le libre échange il faut absolument
laisser faire les choses
voilà moi je pense qu'il ya la
régulation doit dauphin le système doit
s'auto réguler et il ya des directives
qui autorise les médecins à circuler on
la laissait pas le cas l'autorégulation
pour le monde voit qu'il ya déjà des
soucis justement sur les pays les pays
les pays de l'est effectivement si les
déserts médicaux on les transfère de la
france vers les pays de l'est
il n'y a pas d'autorégulation non il
n'ya pas l'oeil a pas d'autorégulation
mais il ya des directives qui autorise
la libre circulation et ça on est
absolument pour la libre la liberté de
circulation dans l'europe c'est le
principe même de l'europe la liberté de
circulation des biens des personnes des
marchandises des de l'argent donc on va
certainement pas lutter contre ça et les
directives européennes autorisent la
reconnaissance de diplômes dans l'union
européenne
donc on va pas remettre ça en cause je
crois qu'il appartient à la roumanie de
faire les efforts nécessaires pour
essayer d'attirer ces médecins et de les
faire revenir le plus possible et nous
on trouvera d'autres solutions eh bien
merci à philippe boulland d'avoir été
avec nous et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouvel europe hebdo ici à bruxelles avec
kathia gilder et françois me donnait
bonne sud est programmé à très bientôt
sur les chaînes parlementaires